I didn't come in with the opportunity to
play right away I had to earn it and and
it was hard I remember taking a walk
with my dad mom around the block I have
a lot of fun I mean we get to play
football for a living I mean what could
be any better than that when I'm playing
football I appreciate it
I'm nowhere else I'm in the present to
me what separates really good players
from great players executes well under
pressure as long as you believe in what
you're doing and you're doing things you
love to do then you can go out there and
be the best at it my family is you know
one and then football is one a when I
watch myself play at times I still don't
think I'm very good I've got to do
things differently and I got to evolve
over time stay hungry stay humble on
three he's an American football
quarterback for the New England Patriots
in his 13 seasons in the National
Football League he's been to the Super
Bowl six times and won four he is
considered among the greatest NFL
quarterbacks of all time he's Tom Brady
and here are his top ten rules for
success I didn't have an easy experience
I didn't have come in as a top-rated
recruit I didn't come in with the
opportunity to play right away
I had to earn it and you know what the
greatest honor I've ever received as a
player is in my fourth year and my fifth
year I was named team captain
that to this day is the single greatest
achievement I've ever had as a football
player because the men in this room
chose me to lead their team and these
were my best friends these were the guys
that that knew that I'd like to work
that knew that I loved football that
knew that I love to play that knew that
I wanted to be the quarterback for
Michigan and all the lessons that I
learned here on State Street and in the
big house that's still what I bring to
practice today and after 14 years I love
the game more than I've ever loved it
but where did I learn the love for the
game where did I learn to practice where
did I learn to compete it was sitting in
the same chairs that you guys are
sitting in today
God pulls away play fake the lowest and
zip
the fourth quarterback in NFL history
down passing plateau we were led to
believe that he's be drafted possibly
second round probably third round they
kept calling quarterback names and we
kept being stunned you see you know
so-and-so get picked and then there's
nine more picks gone until one team that
you think was interested you know that's
you're pretty anxious
we're very distraught with each name
that was becoming worse and worse so I
remember being downstairs for like the
fourth round and I came and gone and the
fifth round was coming and going and all
these other guys were getting hit
beginning of the sixth round he says I
gotta get out of here so he gets up
comes downstairs and grabs baseball bat
and starts walking up the street you
know I don't want to sit around and
leave my hopes get up or I'd rather just
take my mind off it and finally he comes
back into the house and it's about the
22nd pick of the sixth round and he says
I I gotta get out of here the poor guy
the tension in the house is just really
rough and and it was hard I remember
taking a walk with my dad mom around the
block
you
it was just a tough day you know I just
remember being there with my mom and dad
so I love that you know they just were
so supportive of me and and they think
it as emotional as I do and uh you know
finally when the Patriots called I was
so excited you know as I I don't have to
be an insurance salesman you know so my
family was there we were all excited and
thank God I got I got picked here he got
drafted and we were jubilant Brady steps
up Brady on the move
did he get there and he's going to be
marked down inside the one any questions
about the Eagle Daniels Josh McDaniels
listen to the Grady chair what what
keeps you going ma'am
I think it's there's nothing I'd rather
do so I don't have a lot of hobbies you
know I don't you know I play golf every
once in a while but there's something in
my DNA that loves his game and I just I
never wanted to go away no but my goal
was to play you know because I love the
game and I'm not I don't really plan on
doing anything else and I want to play
then you know what else do I say is my
job to take care of myself
year-round so you know eat the right
things to drink the right things to you
know keep my body pliable the way it
needs to be to sustain the hits to make
the throws right no to keep my brain
working the right way and all those
things that's what I think about in
February that's what I think about you
know in August that's what I think about
in November so you know I just love
playing I don't want to I don't want to
go away anytime soon you know being a
situation where they said you're 37 I'm
stepping in 30 so I feel like I'm 27 you
know and I know I just want to keep
doing it so I have a lot of fun I mean
if we get to play football for a living
I mean what could be any better than
that Brady again under a
getting in field goal range well look
that's all Tom Brady there no question
said to him last night
no you're moving around more than I've
seen you move and he goes yep
I'm watching the other quarterback to
the league I'm studying them they're
moving so he has been moving of course
he moved to fill the football when I'm
playing football I appreciate it
I'm nowhere else I'm in the present
there's probably the best part about
best part about my life is that to be in
the present you talk about how do you
enjoy your life how do you find balance
right it's living the present you plead
to live like a kid like why do kids have
so much fun because they just care about
what they're doing yeah and if we
thought about what we were doing all the
time you do that when you're on the
football field it's probably the only
place that I can really do that when I
really truly am my authentic self I mean
a lot of people see it my close close
friends do but when I'm on the football
field there's no it's just raw
takes the step looks right throws it for
wine let's go Patriots why was that easy
career touchdown pass number 421 Tom
Brady now is third all-time in that
category all by his lonesome Sheldon
that was that doing with that
quarterback to me what separates really
good players from great players execute
while under pressure the biggest gains
the greatest stage I think that's what
playing quarterbacks all
Jack just after Brady wiped out of the
back the table stepped up under pressure
otherwise effort
to the near sideline by two defenders
and force down at the 6 yard line what
an effort by Brady to keep the play
alive in the pocket
Brady put up a spot where he could call
forget it I think you know a lot of it
is believing in yourself and believe in
what you're capable and I think as you
grow up there's a lot of people along
the way that will support you and
there's you know as long as you believe
in what you're doing and you're doing
things you love to do then you can go
out there and be the best at it and
that's a you know that should give you a
lot of enjoyment fulfillment in your
life
luckily back display a face to look at
our top stature he's gonna open it what
a play call and they just go in downtown
your father now three kids mm-hmm has
that made you a better player I would
say it's made me a better teammate it's
an evolution as a person and I think my
appreciation for the game is at the
highest it's ever been and I think cuz
the priorities you know you have your
priorities and you make your priority so
my family is you know one and then
football is one a you know and we have
family time it's family time when was
football time it's football time in
under shutter
he makes the room
I run across
overtop of coverage rainy hangs in with
a strike the Gronkowski a decade into
his career the man taken with pic 199
has achieved in all but still feet he
has plenty to prove it's not really a
chip on my shoulder it's just that
feeling that man maybe nobody wants you
when I watch myself play at times I
still don't think I'm very good man
you're still not very fast you know you
got a decent arm you know maybe some
pretty bad reads on that day
that's what gets me up and motivates me
I always wanna feel like I'm the best
quarterback for this team I want to earn
it every single day second down and 20
for the past from the 39 Randy with a
hit you know throw tittle up
laser vibe ready
the outstretched hands of the RO Rivas
in de Brandon LaFell
what hurts attend to the season for 19
yards that's a tight window to throw
that ball into I thought that thing was
going to get there well everyone has
their different belief systems I think
everyone has their different opinions of
you know those types of things that you
talked about certainly as an athlete I
care very much what I put into my body I
think that I'm 38 years old I'm not 22
anymore
oh good you're very sweet thanks but I
you know all those things are important
and all the little things add up to be
big things so when I'm trying to
accomplish things professionally that
you know in a lot of ways you're in
unchartered territory so I've got to do
things differently and I got to evolve
over time I've got the things that may
have worked in the past maybe don't work
as you move forward so the lessons that
I've learned through my own trial and
error I think I'm at that point in my
career I'm very efficient with what I'm
doing so I try to eat healthy I try to
get the right amount of rest I try to do
the right types exercise so I can be on
the field and be available my team I try
to be you know as productive this time
in my career as I was earlier stabbed a
pretty standard drug down right see poor
Gronkowski he makes the catch of the 15
to the 10 double cupboard he still has
the reception and there is still life
for the Patriots I can't believe what I
just saw
Gronkowski is and the club time getting
up he runs a gold round through double
coverage the inside seam and Brady lays
it out of four to ten
rady stands in the pocket
down the right
I'm ready touchdown pass
50
hi
never had one
because let's face it he's the franchise
hey stay hungry stay humble on three one
two three snap directly to james whitey'
was about jumbles of academia
before you talkin about
energy play direct staff delight shovel
back to Amendola we throws the
completions are pretty to the 39 of
Philadelphia Philip easily now
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed I made this video because
Ariel Sanchez Mora asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Tom
Brady's top 10 rules meant the most to
you at the biggest impact leaving the
comments I'll join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
team sports are all about the team and
that was true as a freshman here at
Sarah and it still rings true into my
13th year with the Patriots and as I
first learned here football and life for
that matter is about competition and I
took my first ever reps here for the
fesh for the freshman football team in
1991 and I competed with my friend Kevin
Christofias who's here to be the
quarterback and I lost the competition
but I was excited to be a part of the
team anyway and I was second string that
year and learned from the reps that I
got in practice and I did get a chance
to get into a few games I remember
playing at Reardon it was late in the
game we were losing and my number was
called it was great to finally be
playing until after a few plays coach
Joe Connor yelled from a sideline Brady
you look like you're running in slow
motion which was true then and it's
still true today I know Mom
my mom still thinks I'm the fastest one
out there forever
she says honey don't say that you're
fast we went oh and eight that year and
I hardly played not really the best
start for someone who would end up
making a career playing the game and as
a 14 year old boy I realized how much I
loved the game and just as importantly I
joined the practice in the preparation
working to improve and I realized how
much improvement I needed to make in
order to continue playing past high
school so I worked and I studied and I
listened and I practiced and by my
senior year I was playing well enough to
be recruited by a few Division one
schools and after intense recruiting
process I chose Michigan I took my first
steps onto that playing field in college
as a 7th quarterback on the team and I
was hoping that one day I'd get a chance
to lead the team on the Michigan Stadium
and play in front of 112 thousand fans
but it was pretty clear wasn't going to
happen overnight so there were over 120
practices my first year not to mention
the hundreds of hours of meetings we had
in order to prepare us to play big tent
competition and it all seemed to pay off
when I first got my chance to play and I
was so excited I had all my friends from
home watching maybe some of you my
parents were in the crowd we're ahead
with a huge lead against UCLA I was put
into the game in the fourth quarter and
a coach called my favorite pass play so
I dropped back trying to impress the
coach and I looked off the safety a
little bit and I fired the ball right
over the middle of the field I hit the
player right in stride right between the
numbers and he ran 45 yards for a
touchdown no one touched him just as I
had dreamed the crowd erupted I was
horrified that was UCLA's only points of
the game
a 45-yard interception return for a
touchdown welcome to college football I
wasn't sure my coach would ever put me
in again but we all have experiences
that we dream about and that we look
forward to and when we get them they
don't always go our way I learned that
as a freshman on the football field just
outside of this gym and again I learned
it as second-year player who finally got
a chance to play in college
unfortunately I learned it three weeks
ago and our loss of the Giants in Super
Bowl 46 but I've always been blessed
with the support of my family and
friends and also with coaches that
committed their best to me and with each
opportunity came an understanding of the
things that it takes to be successful
and often this happens through trial and
error and sometimes through outright
failure because lord knows I made plenty
of mistakes so whether I was learning
through watching as I did my freshman
year at Cerro or playing and making
mistakes over the course of my career
I've continued to learn to embrace every
hardship and to seize every opportunity
on and off the field the owner of my
current team rubber craft has told me
time and time again every bump is a
bounce so when I learned very quickly as
a professional was that your job is
always on the line I'm in a what have
you done for me lately type business is
in all businesses there are disclosures
in investments it says past performance
doesn't guarantee future results
that pretty much sums up the NFL and
they're always going to be younger and
hungrier athletes competing to take your
spot I got my opportunity when it come
and starter Drew Bledsoe got injured my
second year and all the practices in
meetings and time spent on these fields
and in this gym and in those classrooms
prepared me to take advantage of the
opportunity in ten years later after
great success in my career I wouldn't
change a day in my life he was skinny
slow right too pretty to be a football
player
but he was smarter than everybody guys
and he studied night and day day and
night nobody works harder than Tom Brady
if you didn't play well on Tuesday and
Wednesday and Thursday and practice in
college I didn't know if I was gonna
start the game so when I come to the
Patriots that's how I treat Wednesday
Thursday and Friday that's it nice
patience on that nice patience
what did he hide
stands in stands and steps up
right rose to the end zone
we ain't down chayo
talk about that
come on
was he firing
he had some urgent
get it I guess Congress and
hey you guaranteed a twin or what
right
come on baby come on
and on the bench man
hey sit on the bed
quarterback sneak back Brady and
touchdown
second dinner to go with the Raider six
the snaptun rate looks at stands Baxter
love it
down to the final yeah
with a minute and forty three to go
personal
ready dropped back to throw whoops fires
right
first and ten
it's already
on his part there
pulse-pounding finish to this one here
walk
41 seconds left
you
the 47-yard
kick is on the way
champions
don't hit me
the best football team in the world
Hey